oh babe you had a crush on me that's
embarrassing we're married still e h
four M potato shape
coffee mug shape smudge smudge middle
finger smudge the rest are all smudges
oh my God you drove
made like 100 million doctors
appointments for ourselves in one week
after this we won't have to go to the
doctor for like 10 years
because we're smart
well you definitely need glasses no he's
not getting glasses I like his face the
way it is if you get glasses I'll
divorce you well you heard her doc too
handsome for glasses no offense
okay if you're allergic to any food
we'll know in a few days I think based
on the redness I might be allergic to
getting stabbed by needles we have
already been to like five different
doctors I got my ankles microwaved x-ray
they took my blood away to use for
science cholesterol test April had her
sinuses removed looked at some guy
looked at my wiener touched it that was
weird and that guy wasn't even a doctor
that
what oh let's get you home and get me
some ice cream
Phil
are you medicine Court uh there's a 500
deductible for dental procedures oh I
think uh you're wrong we have the
insurance thing I believe we're covered
it's still 500
oh because
you know what dinosaurs
ambulance a different ambulance than
what I ran into okay I'm ready good wait
not ready super scared Andy you said you
want to be an action star this is your
chance okay
okay you Natalie follow the action
whatever what do I have to do hold up
this butter knife to my throat and
pretend like you're holding me hostage
we're ready
I don't know it seems a little crazy
just crazy enough to work
oh
my face my face is fine Mikhail Petrov
this is awesomely perfect Burley just
moved in with his rich girlfriend and we
need help with the rent we have a couple
House rolls though yeah sure of course
you can't use the front door you have to
climb in through the back window no
personal phone conversations if you ever
speak to me in Spanish please use the
formal usted and no electricity after 6
pm
you can use as much free electricity as
you want it's free a couple more rules
if you ever watch a sad movie you have
to wear mascara so we can see whether or
not you've been crying there's no noise
a lot on Mondays and no TV after
breakfast
which is my idea uh that I'm trying to
patent so you want to move in tonight
yeah sure that'd be great you want my
gun
eyeballs rats bats vampire teeth boom
vampire teeth good and spiderwebs done
fake blood capsules oh they didn't have
any really
that's gross I love it we are throwing a
Halloween party at our house it's gonna
be the greatest thing ever someone will
die of fun end of murder there's gonna
be beer pumpkins bloody goblins fake
ones it's gonna be awesome we have
decorations dead people that we just
murdered not murdered but pictures of
dead people from TV or movies mutilated
bodies favorite fake ones Candy dancing
tequila all kinds of food and snacks
blood orphans no blood orphans
I
what the hell
someone's back from London no it's not
the queen someone's back from London
it's not Mr Bean oh Mike it's not the
royal baby I think his name is singing
Kiss Me
Oh my God what are you doing here I just
missed you so bad honey I bought myself
a ticket home
you're never gonna need that computer
again
because I'm home for like 19 hours this
is so sweet just like the old days take
a hike Jerry it's Larry now okay take a
hike Larry
morning roomie how'd you sleep well
there were no bed bugs also no bed
I'm gonna go buy a bed Fork I'm sorry
are you eating turkey chili off of a
frisbee
it's pretty cute right
no do you know what cute means what have
you got against turkey chili for
breakfast what have you guys got against
washing dishes we don't have any dishes
okay Burley took them all when he left
now I bet you feel like a jerk
I might need to not stay here anymore no
sorry dude we already spent your money
on a new Xbox 360 and more frisbees to
eat off of you gotta stay oh good okay
all right here's the deal
foreign
we're going to clean this place up okay
and then I'm going to teach you how to
be adults
cool we'll get to be adults
gee golly thanks mister
I guess I kind of hate most things but I
never really seem to hate you
so I want to spend the rest of my life
with you is that cool yes
is it my turn yes
April you're the most awesome person I
have ever known in my entire life I vow
to protect you
danger I don't care if I have to fight
an ultimate fighter or a bear
or him your mom I would take him down
I'm getting mad right now even thinking
about it I'm telling you it's okay
I want to spend the rest of my life
every minute with you and I'm the
luckiest man in the galaxy
of the Rings
engine code
by the power vested in Me by the state
of Indiana I Now pronounce you husband
and wife
don't fly away
okay all right so that one is dead after
we drop off the runners insurance forms
we need to stop by the grocery store and
then we need to sign a suicide pact
because our lives are meaningless babe
we are not boring people wood boring
people get renters insurance even though
it's not legally required where are we I
have never once been to this part of
Pawnee it's the creepy Warehouse
District
it's mostly just raccoons and old car
batteries whoa hang on pull over look at
that
this place is amazing
let's go in
it says here there are 12 closets three
bomb shelters five dumb waiters two and
three eighths baths no kitchens so
fairly standard layout cool is that a
Staircase to Nowhere yes it is good eye
what was this place remember the pony
doll head Factory this was a doll head
Factory no this was a holding cell for
people who went insane on the assembly
line
what's behind this door
a fire pole so this place has had zero
offers people seem to be scared of
the counterfeit being haunted
and disgusting after 47 years living
here
decided to move to Orlando to be closer
to Disney World
we are responsible adults
you know what that means I know we have
money and we are going to buy them out
of this house seriously yes who needs
rental and shirts we're gonna live here
foreign